So we, the book of Romans is a wonderful book.
I'd love for us to go through this entire book,
but we're not gonna be doing that at this time,
maybe in the future.
And Romans 15 is a wonderful chapter
and we're gonna spend three weeks in Romans 15
and we're still not gonna cover everything
that is in this chapter.
But hopefully as we look at this chapter,
we're gonna come to some central truths
as things start to pick up again
and as we kind of move into this new term
as a church in the fall,
as we move towards year two of us gathering together,
we need to be reminded of this central truths
that we see here in Romans 15.
So we're gonna be here for the next three weeks or so.
Let me read Romans chapter 15 verses one to 13.
And it's also in your worship guides if you need it there.
We who are strong have an obligation
to bear with the failings of the week
and not to please ourselves.
Let us each please his neighbor for his good,
to build him up for Christ did not please himself,
but as it is written,
there are approaches of those who reproached you fell on me.
For whatever was written in former days
was written for our instruction
that through endurance and through the encouragement
of the scriptures we might have hope.
May the God of an endurance and encouragement
grant you to live in such harmony with one another
in accord with Christ Jesus
that together you may with one voice glorify the God
and Father of our Lord Jesus Christ.
Therefore welcome one another
as Christ has welcomed you for the glory of God.
For I tell you that Christ has become a servant
to the circumcised to show God's truthfulness
in order to confirm the promises given to the patriarchs
and in order that the Gentiles might glorify God
for his mercy as it is written.
Therefore I will praise you among the Gentiles
and sing to your name.
And again it is said rejoice o Gentiles with his people.
And again praise the Lord all you Gentiles
and let all the peoples extol him.
And again Isaiah says the root of Jesse will come
even he who arises to rule the Gentiles
in him with the Gentiles hope.
May the God of hope fill you with all joy and peace
in believing so that by the power of the Holy Spirit
you may abound in hope.
This is the word of the Lord.
Well, back in I guess 2012 I believe it was.
It was the Queen's Diamond Jubilee.
I don't know if you celebrated it.
We were over in the UK at the time
and we celebrated that.
And it was a great time.
It was basically celebrating 60 years of her reign
and there were lots of festivities
and the kids were out of school
and there was a big concert that was gonna be held.
But we also watched a documentary around the same time
that was all about a song that was being written
and recorded specifically for that occasion.
It was like gonna be the special song for it.
And there was a singer called Gary Barlow.
He was a kind of pop singer, very popular in the UK.
I don't know about here.
But he was tasked with writing the song
and also going across not just the UK
but the British Commonwealth.
So kind of all over the world
to record people singing this song.
And so he literally went to,
he went out to a village in Kenya
and he was recording people there singing.
And he traveled out to Australia
recording people there singing it.
So it was all over and he had the task
of taking all these different instruments
from all over the world,
all of these different people
and harmonizing all of that together
in kind of one voice and one song.
And the song ended up being called Sing.
And they ended up bringing a selection of those people
together for the kind of major celebration
at the Diamond Jubilee.
And the result, if you've never heard the song,
is a really kind of moving and beautiful song.
It was a great tribute to Her Majesty at the time.
On the Bible, there are a number of images
that help us to see the purpose
and calling of the church.
But one of my favorites is what we just read
in Romans 15 and verse kind of five and six.
But when you get to verse six,
you see that our calling in verse five,
it talks about us living in harmony.
So there's that singing word that's there.
And it says, we're doing this that together
you may with one voice glorify the God and Father
of our Lord Jesus Christ.
So the picture here of the purpose of the church
is portrayed before us as singing together in harmony.
So when you sing in harmony,
you're all singing the same song, hopefully,
but you're not all singing the same note, right?
So people are singing different notes,
but it's done in a way that is not kind of working
against each other, but kind of uniquely blending together
in song.
And that's a picture of what our life together
as the people of God is to be like.
It's supposed to be like beautiful music
sounding out in harmony
as we're a diverse body of Christ.
We're united in the gospel.
And what should flow from that
is this beautiful worship of God,
worshiping with one voice.
So for the next three weeks,
I've given a title to what we're gonna be looking at.
And I've given us this, just help us to think about
where we're heading, what we're gonna be looking at.
It's this, it's one voice glorifying God together
through our worship, welcome, and witness.
All right, so that's what we're gonna look at.
One voice, we're all drawn together singing in harmony
as the purpose of the church.
And we're gonna glorify God through our worship,
welcome, and witness.
All right, so Romans 15, what's going on here?
Well, if you go back in the previous chapter
and then into 15, you see that disunity,
a lack of harmony, if you will,
started to creep into the life of the church.
We're gonna look at that in detail more next week.
And so Paul is bringing them back
to this great theme of their song
and showing them how to live harmoniously
as the people of God's the praise of his grace.
So he's speaking to these people
who are threatened with disunity
and trying to unite them again around the gospel.
You know, life in church can get busy.
And in the midst of the busyness
and serving in lots of different ways,
it can be easy to lose sight
of the main thing that we are here for.
And I'm so grateful for a wonderful start
to our first year together.
But as we're looking forward, you know,
it is, let's be clear, it is possible
for disunity to creep in.
So we need to remember the theme of our song,
the thing that unites us and what we are here for,
why we are serving, why are we together as the church?
We need a solid, let's move away from the song thing.
We need a solid three-legged stool
to kind of stabilize us in our worship,
welcome and witness.
And those three words we're gonna kind of see
as we go through Romans 15
are essentially addressing three areas of service
that we're called to in the life of the church.
And there's a Presbyterian theologian
called Edmund Clowney.
And he talked about there's three areas of service.
And one is we're serving God
and we serve God through our worship.
He talks about how we serve one another.
That's the other area of worship.
We do that through nurture is how he would word it.
So we're helping one another to grow in Christ.
And then we also serve the world through mission,
through our witness, making Christ known there.
So those are the kind of three areas we are looking at.
And all three of them are related to each other,
almost like ripples in the water.
All right, so we're, I'm sorry, mixing metaphors.
We're a choir and on a stool in the water,
but it's all gonna come together, don't worry.
All right, so we see Christ, we worship him,
and that affects how we live together
as the people of God.
And as we grow together in his likeness,
we make Christ known in the world around us.
All right, so today we're seeing the kind of central idea
and that first thing of worship.
So if we're gonna glorify God through our worship,
which is what we're focusing on now,
we need to know, well, what does it mean to glorify God?
And what does it mean to worship him?
So that's all we're gonna look at,
the glory of God and the worship of God.
Okay, so first of all, the glory of God.
Three times in these verses that we read,
Paul speaks about the glory of God.
So verse six, why do we join together in one voice?
To glorify God.
Verse seven, why do we welcome one another
as we've been welcomed by Christ for the glory of God?
What are the Gentiles or the nations of the world
praising God for?
By the time you get to verse nine,
well, they're glorifying God.
That's what they're doing.
If you go back to chapter 11 in verse 26,
you see that the glory of God
is the purpose of everything in existence.
It says, from him, through him,
and to him are all things.
To him, be glory forever and ever.
Amen.
So it's impossible to overemphasize the glory of God.
And we could look at specific scriptures that show,
like this is why we've been made.
If you've been saved,
like this is why you've been predestined.
This is why you have been called.
This is why you have been redeemed.
This is ultimately what's gonna happen
when we come to be with the Lord in heaven.
We are going to be glorified.
We're gonna give God glory there.
So what does it mean to give God glory?
Well, the Hebrew word for glory
carries the idea of weight or heaviness.
And it's basically associated with honor.
It's the weightiness of God's presence.
And then when you get to the New Testament in Greek,
the word is doxa.
And so at the end of every month,
at least thus far we've sung the doxology together.
Doxology.
And so we're glorifying God by praising Father, Son,
and Holy Spirit.
So we've got God's glory and view in that song.
So doxa carries the idea of honor or esteem,
but also carries the idea of splendor and radiance,
even beauty.
So when you're looking at the big picture
of what we're talking about,
we're talking about the glory of God.
We're talking about esteeming God,
honoring or the esteem of God,
the honor of God, the splendor of God,
the radiance of God, the beauty of God.
We could put all of that
into kind of three major categories in our minds.
Okay, when we talk about the glory of God,
we're talking about these three things.
One, we're talking about God's,
hang on with me,
God's intrinsic glory.
And by that we mean like the glory of God
is intrinsic to who he is.
It's essential to his being.
When we talk about the glory of God,
this is who God is.
So it's what like when Stephen preached,
right before he was the first martyr of the church
in Acts chapter seven,
he spoke about God as the God of glory.
This is who God is.
He's glorious.
So there's some implications there to say
that it's intrinsic to who he is.
That means that his glory cannot be improved.
All right, so most of you made some improvements
since you woke up this morning
before you came here and we all appreciate it.
And God doesn't need any improvement.
He doesn't need to touch up anything
when it comes to his beauty and splendor
or anything else for that matter.
He is perfect in all of his attributes
just as he is.
His glory cannot be improved.
That also means in the other direction
it cannot be diminished in any way
and it cannot be removed.
I was reading one of the Puritans this week,
Thomas Watson, he's very pictorial
in how he speaks, uses lots of analogy.
And he talked about how human honor
is not essential to our being.
He talks about how a king can have his crown
and his robes and all of that
and be honored as king,
but that crown can be removed.
The robe can be removed.
He can be brought down from his throne,
but that is not the case with God.
His honor cannot be removed.
It's not like a robe or a crown.
It's essential to who he is.
Another thing is it applies to all of who he is,
all of his attributes.
He's glorious in every way.
I love what John Piper said.
He defined the glory of God in this way.
He says, the glory of God is the outward radiance
of the intrinsic beauty and greatness
of his manifold perfections.
Let's put that a bit more simply.
So God's perfections, God's glory
is shining out of his manifold perfection.
Maybe his glory is shining in lots of different ways
as we come to know God in his various attributes.
So you take like a beautiful diamond.
And you could say like,
oh, that diamond is glorious.
Talking about the diamond as a whole.
But you take that same diamond
and you turn around this way
and you see a different kind of glory.
You turn around this way
And so this is what we see in scripture
when we talk about God's beauty.
It's multifaceted.
And the more you get to know God,
the more of his nature is revealed to you,
then the more you're able to praise God
for his glory in those particular ways.
So we can see the glory of his holiness,
the glory of his power, his kindness,
his wisdom, his love, his providence.
And we can go on and on.
He's glorious in all of his ways.
All right, so it's intrinsic to him.
But also we can talk about God's revealed glory.
So God makes his glory known.
So it's intrinsic to who he is,
but that doesn't mean everybody sees that
or honors him in that way.
But he reveals his glory.
And oftentimes in the Old Testament,
the word for God's glory
is linked with his presence being revealed.
So this is why J.I. Packard spoke about God's glory
or defined it as the excellence
and praiseworthy of God set forth in display.
That's the glory of God is God displaying his excellency
and his praiseworthiness.
It's like the brightness of his majestic beauty
emanating from him like rays from the sun.
You know, I was on my back deck this morning
before sunrise.
And as I sat back there, you see the sun
kind of as it rises gradually.
It didn't kind of come on like a light switch.
It was gradual, it was steady,
and it was beautiful.
See all the different colors as the sun rose.
You see God's glory being revealed
in a similar way in Scripture.
There's a kind of gradual revelation of his glory.
It's progressive as it moves on.
So first of all, you see God's glory revealed in creation.
So in Psalm 19, verse one,
the heavens declare the glory of God.
So looking attentively at the beauty of his creation
tells you something about him.
So if you look at, I don't know,
like one of Vincent Van Gogh's self-portraits,
you look at that and you can see lots of things
about Van Gogh as you look at that.
You can see something about his skill.
You can see something about his likeness.
You can see something about his state of mind
or his emotional state at the time
as you look at these paintings.
So what he's created reveals something about him.
So as we're looking out at creation,
or as I was looking at the sun rising this morning,
it's telling me something about God.
It's speaking of his power, his beauty,
and his majesty, among other things.
But even that is just kind of revealing his glory
in a general sense.
We can't look at that and know,
like this is who this God is.
He's got to tell us who he is.
So his glory is revealed not only in creation,
it's also revealed in his word.
So that's where we have special revelation.
God make himself known specifically.
I'm sure we've all had the experience
of maybe seeing somebody and making assumptions
about what that person is going to be like,
but then you actually get to know them
and find out you were totally wrong.
You totally misread them as you hear from them.
They make themselves known to you.
So we're not left to kind of look at creation
and just imagine what God is like.
He's given us specifics about who he is in his word.
This is where he reveals his glory to us,
his character, his nature.
And so 2 Corinthians chapter three, for example,
speaks about how it is in his word
that we behold his glory by his spirit
as his spirit opens our eyes.
All right, to bring us back to Romans 15.
Here you see that Paul is writing
about specific things about God
and how he has revealed himself
in the Old Testament scriptures.
You see that in that first section.
You see that in the kind of litany of different verses
that he has listed out kind of from verse nine
down to the end of verse 12.
He's showing these verses from the Old Testament
speaking about what God is like,
his mercy and his promises
and about what he was going to do
and how it points us to the coming of Christ.
And so the light shines even brighter now.
Okay, so God's glory is revealed in creation
and in his word,
but the brightest place his glory is revealed
is in the person of his son in Jesus.
The scriptures were pointing to the coming of Christ.
That's where God's glory is revealed.
So John said it this way.
John had been with Jesus.
He said in John 1, 14,
we beheld his glory,
the glory as of the only begotten
of the Father full of grace and truth.
Well, the writer to the Hebrews
in Hebrews one in verse three
speaks about Jesus as the radiance
of the glory of God
and the exact representation of his nature.
Or you can go to a place like Colossians chapter one
in verse 19 where it says in Jesus,
all the fullness of God was pleased to dwell.
In other words, those manifold excellencies,
all of those different attributes,
all of his righteousness,
all of his holiness,
all of his power,
all of that is in the person of Jesus.
So Jesus is truly human,
but he's also truly God
and he did not have to improve
on any of those things.
All of God's glory is revealed in Jesus.
So to see him as to see the very God of glory
manifest in the flesh.
You can see some of these particular glories revealed
in Christ in Romans 15.
So verse eight,
I tell you that Christ became a servant
to the circumcised to show what?
God's truthfulness in order to confirm
the promise is given to the patriarchs.
Okay, so throughout the Old Testament,
God promised that he was going to be praised
by people from every nation.
We have some examples of some of those promises.
So when Christ came,
he showed us that yes,
God is true to his words.
So God is truthful.
The glory of God's truthfulness
is revealed in Jesus.
There's another specific glory spoken of here.
He came why?
Verse nine, not just to reveal God's truthfulness
but in order that the Gentiles
might glorify God for his mercy.
So the mercy of God is revealed to us in Jesus.
We deserve God's judgment because of our sin
but Jesus died in our place
that we instead might know God's mercy.
He received the judgment we deserve
so we know mercy in him.
And there are more things we could say
about Jesus as an attribute here
but we'll maybe leave that for home groups
this week to discuss.
If God is so glorious
that his glory cannot be improved upon,
what does it mean then that we glorify God?
Right? So we're called,
what speaks about God's glory here?
It says we glorify the God and Father
of our Lord Jesus Christ.
We said like,
can't be more glorious than he is.
So how can we glorify him if he's already perfect?
What does that mean?
So it's glorious, not just intrinsic
and revealed ultimately then in Jesus.
We can also talk about the ascribed glory of God.
That's the glory that God receives from us.
So this is when we glorify God
but what does that mean?
How is that possible?
Well, I've heard it compared this way many times.
I think this is helpful.
There's a difference between a microscope and a telescope.
Right? So a microscope is when you,
when you're looking at something that is small
and the microscope's making it appear bigger
than it actually is.
Whereas a telescope isn't doing that,
it's doing the opposite thing.
There's something that's big out there
and it's not making that big thing bigger.
It's making that big thing nearer to view.
All right, so this is what it's like to glorify God.
We're not making him any more glorious
but we are reflecting his glory in the world.
We're bringing his glory nearer to view.
That's why we were made.
We were made in the image of God
to reflect his glory in the world.
When you read about why he chose Israel.
So Isaiah 43 verse 7, for example,
he chose Israel for his glory,
to make his glory known in the world,
to reflect who he is.
Same thing with the church.
We've been given hope in Christ
as we saw in Ephesians 1 verse 12
that we might be to the praise of his glory.
That's what it means to glorify God.
To reflect his glory in our lives individually
and collectively as God's people.
So why does this church exist?
All right, Trinity Fellowship, why do we exist?
Do we exist to meet felt needs?
Like we might have all come in here
for different reasons this morning
or joined the church for different reasons.
We've come for like caring community and making friends
and like I hope that happens.
Maybe you've got a passion to see like new people
reached with the good news of Jesus.
Like I hope that's the case.
Like and you wanna join on the mission to do that.
So those are lots of good reasons to join a church.
We could list out a hundred good reasons.
But the most central reason why we exist
is the glory of God.
The most simple way I know how to put this is,
God is the goal.
And everything else is a byproduct.
Or it's the way in which we glorify God together
as a church.
And we can really mess things up
if we put anything else in the center
that that's what we focus on
and we remove that from the glory of God
being the reason why we are doing that thing.
So the glory of God is at the center of all that we do.
And by the way, that raises the quality
of everything that we do as well.
Like if we want to be part of like a caring community,
well, the best way we can become a caring community
is by caring for one another in a way that glorifies God.
If we wanna reach new people like,
well, the best way to do that
is to understand who God is
and his heart for the community
and to glorify God in the way
that we're making Christ known in the community.
You know, you might think of like,
I don't know if you say like, could you cook a meal?
I'm like, well, cook a meal for who?
Like is this like my kid on a Saturday?
Like it might be, I was about to say peanut butter
and jelly, but none of them would have eaten that.
None of them like peanut butter.
So I might make them a sandwich.
But if you say, well, I need you to cook a meal
but it's gonna be for like this award-winning chef.
Like I'm gonna cook them a different meal.
Like so who it's for affects the quality
of what's actually happening.
Okay.
So what is it?
What's the quality of our worship like here?
That's a good question for us to ask.
So let's look then at the worship of God.
We kinda see what the glory of God is.
What does it mean to glorify God in a way
that is honoring to him?
So our opening scripture Psalm 29 verse two
ties glory and worship together.
So verse two, it's on the front of your worship guide.
Ascribe to the Lord the glory due his name.
And then it says, kinda repeats the same idea
but in a different way, worship the Lord
in the beauty or splendor of holiness.
So and this is the kind of God exalting worship
Paul is hoping to provoke in the life of the church
as he writes here.
He's longing that together with one voice
they might glorify the God and father
of our Lord Jesus Christ.
That is worship.
But the word worship isn't used here
but that's what's going on here.
Glorifying God through our worship.
Specifically through the quality of our worship.
A few days ago, I was sitting in a coffee shop
on a big shock and I was having a chat with a guy
who's never been to Trinity before
and he asked me, he said,
oh, what's your worship like at Trinity?
That's an interesting question.
What did he actually mean by that?
What's your worship like at Trinity?
Well, I answered what he was actually asking
and you know what he was asking.
He was asking, well, what's the music like at Trinity?
Like we've somehow turned that into like,
we just mean like the evangelical world in the West
made worship synonymous with singing.
By the way, that's a very recent development.
It's only within like the past like 50 years or so
where in our particular part of the world
where we've started equating the word worship
and singing as being synonymous as the same thing.
Now, don't get me wrong.
Our worship includes our singing.
So you look at verse nine.
You know, this worship recall to,
it involves us singing to the Lord.
But the quality of our worship,
but it's about more than that.
But and also the quality of our worship
isn't about the quality of our singing.
Though I appreciate all of the musicians and singers
and all the rest of you guys are great.
But that's not what's being addressed here.
He's not saying I want you guys
to just sing a little bit better.
When he says I want you to with one voice
to glorify God in harmony.
Like your harmonies are a bit off.
What's he talking about?
What does it mean to worship God in a quality way?
Well, we need to understand what worship is.
Edmund Clowney, once again, to go back to him,
he said this, worship is the response of the creature
to the revealed glory of the creator.
All right, so we see this glory
that God has revealed to us in his word and in Christ.
And true worship is when we respond rightly
to what he has shown us about himself.
And that finds its expression in lots of different ways.
Let's just break it down simply.
It involves our heads, our hearts and our hands.
And all of that is worship.
So worship involves our heads as we respond to the Lord.
If worship is our response to the revelation
of God's glory, then that means we need to be listening
and hearing and heeding to the truth
of what God has told us about himself.
We've got to actually think about who God is.
It's not just a feeling.
And it's not just an action.
Thinking about the actual God
who's revealed himself in his word.
So what did Jesus say in John 4 verses 23 and 24,
that God is seeking those who will worship him
in what, spirit and truth.
So true worship involves the truth.
If we're gonna worship God rightly,
then that means thinking about him rightly as well.
We're not just feeling good about our general ideas
about a vague God.
If that's what worship is,
we just need to really pump up the feelings.
Well, I mean, there's better ways that we could do that.
We just really get our emotions pumping here.
We've got to be thinking rightly about God as well.
And this is true individually, but also as a church.
It's important that the word is central in our worship.
Well, let's move on.
It doesn't just involve our heads,
it also involves our hearts.
So worship that glorifies God is worship
that comes from the heart,
from a heart that is truly after him.
When verse five in Romans 15 speaks
about living together in harmony,
the word living together actually conveys a sense
of having a similar,
or a oneness of inner purpose
or a shared passion, living together in harmony.
Share the same passion, be of the same heart and mind.
We'll look at this more in detail next week,
but they were having these kind of worship wars
in the church to borrow a phrase,
but it wasn't over the music.
What were they fighting over in the church in Rome?
It was what kind of food is acceptable to eat in worship?
And also should they observe certain holy days
and not others?
And the answer given as to,
how do they make a call on this?
Well, what to do?
Well, it comes to this.
If you look in chapter 14 and verse six,
it says, what matters most is that they are,
they know that they're motivated by the honor of the Lord.
So like this person chooses to eat this thing,
they think they're free to.
Well, they're doing that to honor the Lord.
This other person refrains from eating this thing over here
and they're doing that in order to honor the Lord.
They say, well, the main thing is that you're both
motivated by the same thing,
which is the glory and esteem of God,
keeping God's glory central.
All right, so desiring the honor of God from the heart
is what's going to unite them together in worship.
They're all besotted together by the glory of the Savior.
Now, don't misunderstand this when it comes to like,
oh, we're really, we're in love with the Savior
and we have these feelings towards Him.
Now, that doesn't mean that worship
always involves a certain positive mood.
We've just spent the summer in the Psalms
and we've seen lament over and over in those early Psalms
and that is worship too.
It's responding rightly to God from the heart
even when you're not feeling well.
Like I'm bringing that before the Lord too.
So what does a heart of worship look like?
It's exalting the glory of God
by humbling ourselves before Him.
That's what a heart of worship is.
In the Old Testament, there's two words used for worship.
One is, one means literally to bow yourself down.
It's recognizing the honor of somebody
by bowing yourself down to the ground.
And this is how we honor the Lord in worship
by bowing before Him.
So the quality of our hearts in worship
isn't like our impressiveness or all the good things
that we can bring before the Lord.
The quality of...
The quality of our worship will be seen in coming before God.
Let's put it this way, in humility before the Lord.
Not trying to bring our own impressiveness before Him
but holding out the empty hands of faith in our need,
receiving His grace and glorifying God
because of what He has done.
Saying, none of this comes from me, it's all from you
and you are the one who deserves all the glory.
That is what it is to bow before the Lord in worship.
It's like what Paul says in Romans 12, 1.
Having just explained all the glories of the gospel
in chapters 1 to 11, he says,
I appeal to you, therefore, brothers, by the mercies of God
that you present your bodies as a living sacrifice to the Lord.
Which is your spiritual worship.
So we're seeing this is our Lord.
He is worthy to be praised.
And He's done this for us in Christ.
And so we're giving ourselves to Him.
That's the service He's looking for.
By the way, that's the other Old Testament word
used for worship is service.
So we're offering ourselves up to Him in service.
If you want to know what the English word stands for
is worship is where we get that word.
It's a great word for what worship truly is.
It's recognizing the worth of Jesus
and giving ourselves freely to Him.
Lastly, it involves not just our head
and our hearts, but also our hands.
So when God makes Himself known to us in our minds
and we give Him our hearts,
that then finds an outward expression in our actions.
Now here in Romans 15, that is what's being addressed
as how we fellowship with one another,
how we treat one another.
And that is an act of worship
as we care for one another as we've been cared for by Christ.
It involves more than that too.
It's other areas of service.
So Hebrews 13 verses 15 and 16 says,
through Christ,
then let us continually offer up a sacrifice
of praise to God.
That is the fruit of lips that acknowledge His name.
Alright, so as we praise God, that is worship.
But also it says, do not neglect to do good
and to share what you have
for such sacrifices are pleasing to God
as we care for the needs of others.
That is an act of worship to God.
So the united worship that we are called to
involves lots of practical things.
And it involves things like we're doing today,
prayer, listening to God's word.
It involves things like receiving communion,
caring for one another in community, singing praises,
and proclaiming Christ to the world.
All of that is worship.
And I've said it before, I'm going to say it again.
I appreciate all the ways that people serve in this church.
And it's been wonderful to see.
And all of that is worship if it's done
with a heart that is after the Lord.
So I hope we continue to serve
within the life of this church.
But don't serve because you think
the church plant is worth it.
Because pretty soon it's not going to feel worth it anymore
when it gets hard.
And don't serve out of a kind of self fulfillment.
Like this is my area.
This is tied to my identity.
Like this is where I'm serving.
What should motivate us in our service,
whether it's children's ministry or music
or a day like Founders Day, yesterday,
or whatever area of service you're serving in,
setting up, what should motivate us
is the worthiness of Jesus.
He is why we do it.
It flows from a passion to glorify God.
And if we all have that same passion,
that is what's going to unite us together.
And we're going to glorify in our worship.
Let me end with this.
I saw a remarkable photo.
It's taken back in 2015.
And it's of a humpback whale.
Beautiful, elusive.
This person took the photo.
But what is so remarkable about this photo
of this humpback whale kind of coming out of the water,
revealing his majesty, so to speak,
is the guy in the picture behind it.
Because there's a guy in a boat
behind the humpback whale.
And he's completely oblivious to what's in front of him.
He's glued to his phone.
He's just scrolling through his phone.
Is it because he's just scrolling?
He misses the majesty,
the greater glory that is right
in front of him by just scrolling away.
So as we're coming to the Lord in prayer,
let's ask ourselves this.
Am I captivated by the worthiness
of Jesus, or am I distracted by lesser things?
Is he the one I treasure above all else?
Is he at the center of my thoughts, my motivations,
the reason why I exist, the reason why I serve?
Well, let's all offer ourselves up afresh to him
in worship because he is worthy. Let's pray.
Lord, I pray that you would make us a people
who glorify you
by uniting together in praise of your name.
We're afraid that you'd make us a people of worship.
Lord, it is only by your spirit that we are able to see
more and more of your worthiness,
the glories you've revealed to us in Jesus.
Lord, I pray that you'd help us to see more and more of your beauty.
And so I pray that as you open our eyes to see more of you,
that we would be ready and willing and eager
to give ourselves completely to you
because you are worth it.
And so all too often,
would I and I know the rest of us
get distracted by the things of this world
and I pray that you would draw our minds and our hearts
and our wills back to you.
I pray that you'd make us a people
who truly worship you from our hearts
and with our lives together for the glory of your name.
Amen.